I wish we had thought of that history
history hanging you got a good name here
you guys gotta take a little pride like
you came in you thought he was being
sarcastic about this being a nice house
beautiful huh nice house
well I forget that you guys are from New
York yeah we live live in one Betty
Tokyo yeah because you go don't you know
when you go go on the road like you know
you go on the road yeah Oklahoma where
and you go you see like a compound sure
hey go how much is that they're like oh
that's 9 grand yeah right right so it's
like you know this is you know it's a
sort you stick it's hard it's which is
real money yeah yeah yeah no but the
thing is - and cuz out here because how
the Eastern hemmings do well out here
just like in New York it's all about
Eastern how many money that's they'll
say eastern hemisphere yeah ok my fault
we love the Eastern Hemis absolutely
yeah yeah but it's a lot about it's all
about the Chinese money in New York you
know the thing is it's like the
buildings they don't want to sell you in
a part like I'm trying to sell my
apartment right now they like there
ain't enough Chinese money in here so we
got a Chinese money back into New York i
knees money is here - oh yeah yeah yeah
China's everywhere bro I know yeah I'm
[ __ ] how do you feel about the China
China know the people the people buying
all the property and them I got no
problem with them because I'm a property
owner now I like the Chinese ordered a
day - Chinese I don't know I 100 some on
my door today - [ __ ] Chinese kid
because all the people I'm telling you I
agree with that Chinese men are the best
husband hundred percent because it's
like it's like okay she goes to school
told these [ __ ] woke kids in Brooklyn
and they're like are you vaccinated or
like for the Chinese they don't give a
[ __ ]
the Chinese say they don't care it's
like they'll give my kid whatever they
don't ask about peanut allergies one of
the Chinese grandmother gave my kid a
live shrimp and a bag the other day and
we don't know is this a toy food they're
like I might eat oh I didn't [ __ ]
know but I want worth they're playing on
the abacus and [ __ ] they talked about
the Sun they do full [ __ ] Chinese [ __ ]
I don't know if they're Korean or
whatever but it's China
I'm gonna let it go I'll kiss you right
in the [ __ ] lips last night that we
are European you kissed my hand three
times absolutely is that a [ __ ] New
York thing John you got confused I
[ __ ] like you dude I I've always
liked you I've been a fan you since day
one and we came in and you started
eating that bull dick on the Opie and
Anthony I was like I'm [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah because every [ __ ] spirit you're
fun guy yeah we got good energy yeah I
got great energy yeah I know you're not
gonna like that now but yeah don't
[ __ ] lose it if you come in and
you're wild and you're in your free
spirit yeah and you're kind of like me
cuz they call me Chrissy bug chaser
because I like to chase buck and what I
mean by that is you know guys homosexual
community they go and they have the guys
who don't have AIDS have sex with guys
you do have AIDS because of the feeling
of chasing the bug and I'm not a gay guy
but but I do chase the bug I do go wrong
I'm actually dealing with residual
diarrhea right now from antibiotics I
took the long term chlamydia yeah what's
what's Shyvana now it's basically a
prophylaxis for people who are let's say
if you're in a relationship with a guy
with HIV okay I am so to continually
have to continue to have sex with them
without getting the yeah where you're no
condom you can do it with no condom
yeah I can do with no car it's a
prophylaxis right but that's still I
feel like that's still like playing
Russian no because it's the bug chasing
that's what it's about
I don't do that who I've been celibate
he's had chlamydia about three times
recently like CVS is like his cheers he
walks in they know is all right I'll
just toss a bottle in and they know
what's up but I've made a commitment now
to my family and to myself to just you
know I'm celibate I'm only gonna have
sex with a woman who I think could
potentially one day be my girl yeah
that's what I'm doing these guys on the
side so you and guys like yeah yeah but
so then you um you had an addiction do
you think I was a full full-blown sex
addict a full sex addict you know just
unprotected sex with everybody just wild
yeah really living life crap are you
going are you
treating that with meetings that whatnot
like yeah groups and stuff I went to one
and the lady told me she was like you
know you're not you're not as sick as
you think yeah she was like but you know
try celibacy and it's been eight weeks
besides someone blowing in Denver I've
been celibate with women no I don't know
about guys yeah it's like you have sex
with so many ways had sex you so many
women that like right if a couple raises
slipped in that oatmeal yeah you
wouldn't notice what so many women we
call gay guys raise a guy if a couple
guys slipped in there like raisins he
wouldn't taste it no dude does our
podcast I can't say his name that's just
like you
really yeah yeah handsome very funny
like you right but is in knee-deep in
puss puss yeah right I see for me guys
like Yanis and I'm sorry for putting us
no no I'm American I'm he's Yanni almost
yeah he's almost like yeah if you
stretch my eyes a little farther apart
yeah don't think everything's a little
disproportion right you know you're you
know people's faces are like one inch
like away from being in cell yes in cell
photos were like they just put the eyes
it's like they look like in cells but
they do this and their bread pan yeah
right no that's just exactly all
beautiful people are like that they just
hinge on being really disgustingly ugly
sure just one one millimeter away from
that for that yeah yeah it's true
because God didn't cause a trend when
they were making us I don't know I don't
know I I bought something though right I
know you're going I know where you're
fishing tonight cuz I feel like he right
when he made you yeah he took a day yeah
like he's like get the chins in right
right and all that stuff right
any concentrator right but with me well
I think I think God's German that's why
I think the wrong people won the war
[Laughter]